okay she's gonna get one drink just poke  around see what they've got classic I  have to have something healthy okay nuts  and fruit great anything that's yes okay  I'm leaving  waiting I cannot not get Doritos I'm not  a crazy person  all right bro you know what to do beef  jerky for proteins a gummy worm for  energy yep six liters of water stay  hydrated good  oh good bucks for vitamin K got it hmm  this might work perfect good morning  [Music]  I have a good question is your name  Jennifer don't answer there's two cars  in the lot with a vanity plates both  Jennifer which brings me to do you carry  mint chocolate chip ice cream anymore  I like the mint but I like the chip too  let me check the ice cream section  there's an ice cream section hahaha  everyone's here